so we're playing the game and I was
holding on to I was holding on to the
flanker who was the captain at the time
and hold him into the Rock and he just
stood up and boom and just belted me you
know and it was in front of the
referee because in professional stuff
you wouldn't get that yeah there's no
way you'd get that because you got
cameras everywhere on you and so he was
just like not not having any of that W
fully deserved that and then penalty
you're off and he's like what just for
smacking an all you
know and then yeah after the game after
the game comes up you know buys me a
beer he's like sorry mate head to I said
I was r that you
[Laughter]
did